[Musique]
ils n'ont plus de lait entier tu appelles
quelqu'un à ce sujet
ouais j'entends des super villes ouvrir un
deuxième endroit tu peux les déplacer devenir
une image d'accord je vais rester avec toi
je pense que j'en avais peut-être besoin tout
seul  temps
[Musique]
comment es-tu arrivé ici,
j'ai veillé mon ami iotus
qui est vraiment fou et puis j'ai trouvé
cet endroit c'était vraiment mignon alors je viens juste d'
arriver c'était ouvert j'arrive au poivre
j'ai juste un  quelques choses que je dois
faire qu'est-ce que tu dois faire là-dessus
il n'y a rien ici
allez allons-y j'ai peur de moi j'ai
un concert j'avais ce bar appelé Blue Room
ton stepford une chose que je ne sais pas  il a
dit si vous ne répondez pas à votre choix, ça a
été une nuit au monde pour les
traverser Je veux t'emmener dans l'un de mes
endroits préférés oh j'écris juste le
temps de te donner c'est comme si c'était sûr
un gars de  Vegas est arrivé
hier soir, il a dit que tu avais gagné beaucoup d'
argent, je suis désolé, je veux que tu me fasses confiance
[Musique]
une nuit en prison  une nuit en prison qui
ne m'arrive pas j'ai l'
impression qu'on va peut-être dans des directions différentes
[Musique]
tout est possible
toi